Chintan Post reporter Michael Dobbs
discusses his book one minute to
midnight Kennedy Khrushchev and Castro
on the brink of nuclear war
I'm Alan Cooperman I'm senior editor at
book world The Washington Post book
section and I'm delighted on behalf of
the Washington Post in the Library of
Congress to welcome you to the National
Book Festival on the ball
I'm pleased very pleased to have the
honor to introduce to you another of my
colleagues Michael Dodd
Michael Michael is a tenacious reporter
and I want to tell you just a very quick
story about that a few years ago Michael
was on vacation with his family in Sri
Lanka and he was swimming on a beautiful
day in the ocean when this little thing
called the tsunami hit he was in the
water
Michael survived Raps miraculously
perhaps not but there was nothing
miraculous about what he did next
he found a working telephone line he
phoned in a story Michael has been a
reporter at the post for more than 25
years now he covered the Solidarity
uprising at the garage shipyard in 1980
he covered the Tiananmen uprising in
China he covered the fall of the Soviet
Union in this election cycle he's the
guy who's been awarding those Pinocchio
noses to the candidates on the Post fact
checker column he speaks seven languages
including Russian and serbo-croatian and
his magnificent books include a
biography of Madeleine Albright down
with big brother the fall of the Soviet
empire and most recently one minute to
midnight a narrative history of the
Cuban Missile Crisis ladies and
gentlemen please welcome a tenacious
truth teller
Michael Dom's
well thank you very much Alan for that
untruthful introduction at least
exaggerated introduction can you hear me
now so you're probably wondering why or
all these journalists up here and
there's David Marin Mariners I'm going
to be followed by Rick Atkinson Walter
Isaacson viral journalists now suddenly
posing as historians or biographers and
the cynic might say that it reflects the
dismal state of the newspaper industry
that we've all taken refuge in another
industry that is with equally poor
prospects but I think it really says
something about the nature of journalism
and our eagerness to find out about the
world to find out about how the world
works another journalist turned
historian Robert Caro Caro said that he
became historian because he could no
longer explain politics through
journalism and that's why he started
studying writing his succession of
biographies and studying the life of LBJ
he thought that he could understand much
more about how politics works and about
what happens in the Oval Office through
history and through open records than he
could as a journalist and I agree with
him and I think that history will show
that even the most tenacious journalist
the journalists were the best sources
when they described this period that
we're going through it right now are
only really scratching the surface but I
as a historian can go back to an event
that took place actually 47 years 46
years ago today on October 27th 1962 the
day that was known around the White
House as Black Saturday probably the day
that the world came closer than ever
before or since to nuclear war and I can
tell that story not only by
eavesdropping on the debates in the Oval
Office
through the tape recordings that JFK
made but also I know what Fidel Castro
was doing I know what Nikita Khrushchev
was doing I know what was happening in
and around Cuba I know the forces that
were preparing to invade Cuba I can give
a picture of this that was absolutely
impossible at the time and I think my
book and others like it address tropical
questions they address the question that
we're examining right now of you know
who has what it takes to be the next
commander in chief what is the essence
of presidential decision-making when
faced with a supremely grave national
crisis how does the president take
decisions who are his advisors and this
is all the stuff of the material for my
book when I first said I was going to
write about the Cuban Missile Crisis a
lot of people said that I was crazy that
they've been hundreds of books written
about it there's even been a movie
several documentaries academics have
been studying it for all their lives
what more is there to say about this
subject but the fact is that most of
these books take just one slice of the
crisis they're people who's studying the
tapes in the Oval Office there are the
people who studying what Chris job was
doing or they're people studying looking
at from a military perspective I wrote
this book because there was no book a
book that I wanted to read didn't exist
and that was a day by day and all by our
and sometimes minute by minute narrative
of what was happening not just in the
Oval Office but in Cuba and the Soviet
Union and I spend half the book on this
particular day October the 27th 1962
Black Saturday and one of the things I
discovered when I did my research of
course I took the meetings of the XCOM
which were all taped and transcribed
they were extraordinarily valuable and
they a
allow you to eavesdrop on what the
president is advisers were saying but I
took that and I tried to mesh it
together with what was happening in
other places with what was happening in
a submarine that was a Soviet submarine
armed with a nuclear torpedo underneath
the Caribbean what was happening in a
u-2 spy plane that had got lost over the
Soviet Union at the same time what was
happening in the Kremlin and when I
started putting all these things
together the first thing I discovered
was that the debates in the Oval Office
were often out of sync with what was
happening in the rest of the world that
misleading information was coming into
the Oval the Oval Office the Cabinet
Room the White House and in sometimes in
some cases inaccurate information and
certainly incomplete information there
was the famous Watergate question what
did the president know and when did he
know it and the question that I thought
was really more pertinent in studying
the Cuban Missile Crisis is what didn't
the president know and when didn't he
know it because it was the things that
he didn't know that could have caused
the situation there crisis to spiral out
of hand and could have led to ultimately
to a nuclear war so what are a few of
the things he didn't know in October
1962 the first thing was that he had
been completely misinformed about the
number of Soviet troops on Cuba there
were not a 6,000 to 8,000 Soviet troops
on the island at that time as he was
told by the CIA
there were 43,000 heavily armed combat
troops who would have resisted and a
u.s. invasion of the island furthermore
these troops were armed not only with
the medium-range nuclear weapons that
could hit the United States and were
targeted on cities like Washington and
New York
they were also armed with tactical
nuclear weapons small small relatively
small sized warheads about the size of
the bomb that destroyed Hiroshima that
would have been used against a u.s.
invading force in the event that Kennedy
had ordered an invasion of the island
and I show in my book how at this most
critical moment of the crisis the 26th
to 27th of October 1962 the Soviets
began dispersing both their tactical
nuclear weapons and moving up their
warheads to the missile bases by the way
I made a mistake about it I realize now
it's September not October so we're one
month off but the Soviet troops on Cuba
on the night of the 26th 27th October
they brought up a nuclear cruise
missiles to within 15 miles of the
Guantanamo Naval Base Khrushchev earlier
that week had met with an American
visitor in the Kremlin and he had told
them that if you want to find out what
will happen when you invade Cuba just go
ahead the first thing that will happen
is that Guantanamo will be destroyed at
that time people thought this was just a
bluff but I have shown through my
research that the convoy actually moved
up to the periphery of the naval base
and the these weapons were under the
control of a Soviet captain who although
he didn't have authority to fire them
had physical control over the weapons
and could have fired them in the event
of the u.s. attack on Cuba
the president also didn't know where the
warheads were for the weapons that were
aimed at the United States the by
sending CIA
or air force you to planes over Cuba we
had discovered where the missile sites
were but the key question
the critical question was when would the
missiles be mated with the warhead so it
was critically important to find out
where the warheads were and when they
could be mated with the missiles
themselves and I established for the
first time in my book the locations of
the warhead storage centers and also the
fact that again on this same very
critical day October 26 to 27
the Soviets dispersed some of the
warheads to two of the missile sites in
central Cuba where they could have been
mated with the warheads within one and a
half to two hours and far the targets
one of the targets one of their targets
of this particular missile site was
Washington DC
the president also didn't know that the
Soviets had submarines in the Caribbean
that were armed with nuclear torpedoes
he was aware about the presence of
Soviet submarines in the Caribbean but
he wasn't aware that they were armed
with nuclear torpedoes now I've talked
to some of the people on board those
submarines and the conditions were
terrible
after the voyage across the Atlantic
they went distances they should never
have gone temperatures down below or
about 110 degrees the crew members were
getting is fixated they were didn't know
what was happening about because they
were out of communication with Moscow as
long as they would blow water and we
tried to bring these submarines to the
surface by dropping down depth charges
on top of the submarines now from the
point of view of the Soviet submarine
commander he didn't know what was
happening he didn't know if nuclear war
had been was erupting over his
had he didn't know that these were [ __ ]
charges rather than live live grenades
he were in one particular ship in one
particular submarine the commander is
said to have ordered the arming of the
nuclear torpedo and was only dissuaded
at the last moment from using it against
the US Navy surrounding his submarine
now not only that it's I think one of
the things I another thing that I
discovered in researching this book is
that the myth of the commander-in-chief
exercising complete control over his
forces is just that a myth we've seen in
Iraq how you know the best military
plans can fall apart as soon as they
come in contact with the enemy and that
certainly happened during the Missile
Crisis I just mentioned one dramatic
episode that illustrates that again the
same day Black Saturday there were
routine missions going on from Alaska to
send you twos to the North Pole to
gather up radioactive fallout from
Soviet nuclear tests these missions have
been going on for months and nobody
particularly may paid much attention to
them the Air Force Chiefs
were barely aware that they were still
continuing and certainly the president
had no idea that they were taking place
at the same time as the crisis now as
luck would have it on this very day a
guy called Captain Charles multi-sets
off in his u2 to the North Pole to
collect the radioactive samples and he's
blinded by the aurora borealis this is
before the days of GPS systems and
electronic navigation and his navigation
systems failed him they mainly consisted
of of navigating by the Stars which he
can see and instead of
turning back and coming back to Alaska
he ended up over Soviet territory on the
most critical day of the Cuban Missile
Crisis in fact the most dangerous day of
the Cold War he found out that something
was wrong
when he heard Russian music balalaika
playing over his radio set he didn't
know it at the time but the Soviets had
set up MiG's to try to shoot him down
and we had sent up from Alaska f-102
interceptors armed with nuclear weapons
to take out the Soviet any Soviet
airplanes coming across the Bering
Strait this is really when we needed
Sarah Palin sitting in Alaska watching
this watching those flames coming across
the Bering Strait Pacific's are really
probably the most critical time in
Alaska for the last half-century but any
rate when Kennedy found out about this
by the way Kennedy was not informed by
the air force of that the plane was
missing until it had already exited
Soviet airspace after 1/2 1/2 hours in
Soviet airspace and he finally they
finally told him and he said well
there's always some son of a [ __ ] who
doesn't get the word
he was pretty phlegmatic but the next
day Chris Jaffa wrote to Kennedy and
said you know this was an incident that
could have caused a nuclear war so both
sides made huge miscalculations during
the Missile Crisis this happens in any
war but when you're talking about the
early stages of manipular war you can't
afford miscalculations I mean any
miscalculation miscalculation can lead
to a nuclear exchange Chris John Smith's
calculations are obvious he sent nuclear
missiles to Cuba he thought that he
could achieve a fait accompli without
the Americans finding out about it and
Kennedy would have no option but to
accept the presence of these missiles in
Cuba but Kennedy also made mistakes I'll
just mention a few of them he as has
been mentioned in the current
presidential campaign he was very
unprepared when he went to a summit
meeting with Nikita Khrushchev in Vienna
during the first day of the first year
of his presidency and Christian
Christian believe him at that meeting
Chris jobs later told his aides that he
thought Kennedy was too weak and too
intellectual and Kennedy understood that
he would have to repair the damage it
would take him some time to convince
Chris Jeff that he wasn't weak that he
could defend American interests then of
course there was the famous Bay of Pigs
fiasco again in 1961 in which Kennedy
allowed the CIA to talk him into
supporting an invasion by CIA X Isles of
Cuba which ended disastrously he didn't
provide support for the invasion so you
know it ended in complete failure the
exiles were rounded up and then there
was Operation Mongoose which some of you
may have heard of but after the collapse
the failure of the Bay of Pigs catch a
key and his brother Bobby decided that
they would use clandestine methods to
bring down Castro and there are whole
series of Mickey Mouse sabotage
operations including some assassination
attempts against Fidel himself that had
no impact whatsoever in the sense that
they were never stood any chance of
success and little sabotage was actually
carried out but they were there was
enough to them to convince the Russians
and the Cubans that the Kennedys were
out to get Fidel and this was one of
Christians motivations in sending
missiles to Cuba in the first place and
certainly one of Castro's motivations in
accepting the Soviet missiles on his
territory
so uh I don't by any means excuse
Kennedy's errors but we come to the
critical moment in the crisis which was
again on Black Saturday around about
lunchtime most be is the YouTube pilot
is lost over the the over Soviet
territory another YouTube pilot major
Anderson has been shot down on a YouTube
reconnaissance mission over Cuba Kennedy
doesn't know it but he del Castro has
gone to the Soviet embassy in Havana and
urged Chris job to use nuclear weapons
in the event of a US invasion of Cuba
and another letter arrives from Chris
jobs saying that we're prepared to take
our missiles out of Cuba if you take
your missiles analogous missiles out of
Turkey and at that time if you study the
XCOM transcripts you'll find that
everybody in the room is against taking
that deal the only person who is in
favorite is the president himself he
says that in a wagon of war and
particularly if we're going to a nuclear
war we have to have a damn good reason
to explain it to the American people and
I'm not going to go to war or a few
obsolete missiles in Turkey I think at
that point he was the only person in the
room who was thinking in global terms
the others were thinking very narrowly
the Security Advisor Mac Bundy was
thinking about the cohesion of NATO or
US relations with Turkey Curtis LeMay
who wasn't in the room well that was
butting in from the Pentagon thought
that we should finish with the Soviets
once and for all we should attack the
Soviet we should attack Cuba with from
the air followed up by an invasion
within seven days
that was the formal recommendation of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff at that moment
and we can see that it would have led to
disaster because a US invasion of Cuba
but easily have resulted in a Soviet
tactical nuclear attack on the American
beachheads and possibly also on
Guantanamo so Kennedy was the only
person who was thinking yes we can win a
nuclear war in the sense that we have
many more nuclear weapons than the other
side but what is the point of winning a
nuclear war under these circumstances
even if one he once asked what would
happen if even one Soviet missile got
through and he was told that it would
lead to half a million six hundred
thousand US casualties and he said
that's the same as happened to us in the
Civil War and which it's taken us a
century to get over that so at that what
does he do he sent his brother to the
Soviet embassy to reach an understanding
with the Soviet ambassador that the
Soviets will pull themselves out of Cuba
we will not say that we're pulling our
missiles out of Turkey but they will be
quietly withdrawn within the next couple
of months so how does my my research
into the crisis affect my general
understanding of it I think for many
years it's being taught in places like
the Kennedy School at Harvard and this
was the spin of the administration as a
kind of eyeball to eyeball confrontation
between Chris Jaffa and Kennedy in fact
it was very different it was really the
two leaders on both sides struggling to
contain these chaotic forces of history
that they themselves had unleashed and
in the end paradoxically Khrushchev ends
up on the same side as Kennedy he's also
been through the war he's horrified by
the idea of a nuclear war and in the end
both Kennedy and Khrushchev find a way
out so they end up being on the same
side and you know what they I think the
significance of what happened in October
1962 is that they regain control of
these chaotic forces of
I would like to take a few questions
before my time is up thank you very much
[Applause]
did Kennedy Khrushchev for Castro ever
verbalize their understanding maybe of
each other in the way that George W Bush
seemed to understand Vladimir Putin
Kennedy Kennedy and Khrushchev well
Kennedy only met Chris job once as far
as I recall in Vienna he certainly
didn't say that I've looked into mr.
Khrushchev eyes and that was in a very
shocking moment actually for Kennedy in
he Khrushchev talked to him brutally
and the British Prime Minister Harold
Macmillan said it was rather like the
experience was rather similar to
Chamberlain going to Munich and being
lectured or bullied by Hitler it really
gave Kennedy something to think about
so he never got the opportunity to carry
on the kind of conversations with Chris
job that Bush has had with Putin or even
you know Roosevelt and Truman have with
Stalin anybody else right side hi crusty
on the right I'm wondering I'm a
Washington Post annex or if we don't
mind a question about the Washington
Post uh I talked to Deborah how they are
emailed Iran buds Minh if there could be
more in-depth explanation and coverage
of legislation the sports pages go into
a lot more depth cover the whole game
compared to the political pages in any
in any newspaper and it would help the
citizenry had a better understanding of
legislation other than the ninth-inning
when they're doing the voting well I'll
pass your message on to our
congressional reporters I mean the of
course you know a lot of attention has
been consumed by the election campaign
you could argue that these are precisely
the issues that should be addressed
during the election campaign I'm not
here to defend the Washington Post
I am question well you know
case must have known something about
Russia bringing missiles to Cuba a year
before they you know in October 61 that
up to October 62 why didn't they do
something about it
in the year before the crisis came about
well the Soviet military buildup in Cuba
only really began in the summer of 1962
in August when the first contingent of
Soviet troops and the commanders arrived
and we certainly observed you know this
incredible Armada crossing the Atlantic
and there was a lot of debate about you
know what exactly the Soviets were
delivering to Cuba and it's obvious they
were you know delivering military
equipment but the question was was this
offensive or was it defensive the
missiles didn't arrive until about the
middle of September
so it took the intelligence community a
month from the arrival of those missiles
in Cuba to figure out definitively that
they had the missiles by sending you to
spy planes over the island yeah yes
how did Kennedy go about dealing with
his national security staff when they
all were opposed to his his desire to
not go to war and also in the movie is
it a pie Praful that the scene with the
Navy captain was going out to meet the
Soviet our manner and he tells the Navy
captain don't don't do anything to unit
from me yeah it's quite a lot of I mean
the movie isn't too bad in the sense
that it captures the atmosphere at the
time but that scene is totally
apocryphal there was no direct line of
communication between the president and
the Navy captain in fact as I show my
book the Soviet ships never reached the
blockade line at least the missile
carrying ships Chris job had turned them
around a day before so at the at the at
this eyeball to suppose that eyeball to
eyeball moment the two navies were about
eight hundred seventy eight hundred
miles part that
one reason why say that the real risk of
war in October 62 did not come from this
direct confrontation it came from the
accident the freak accidents that can
happen as soon as you start putting your
military machinery into motion and your
first question was how did Kennedy deal
with his national security advisors
right for opposed his decision not to go
to war but well most of them were
actually urging him to take more
aggressive action against Cuba then he
did and you know at the beginning
Christian Kennedy was sympathetic to
that argument he had the great luxury of
being able to wait a week he didn't have
to go on television immediately and say
that the missiles were there he had the
luxury which is probably inconceivable
today of thinking about what he was
going to do for an entire week before
actually announcing it the American
people and to the and to the Soviets and
during that wait he decided the best
course of action would be to implement a
blockade to give Khrushchev the off the
chance to withdraw his missiles without
a confrontation I mean in the end you
know Kennedy was the if there may be 13
people in the room but there's only one
person who has the decisive vote yep
would you please comment on the United
States current relationship with Russia
visa V Georgia and other Eastern
European nations and how dangerous do
you consider the current situation and
how could it possibly escalate into
something truly dangerous
I think whatever you think of Putin and
whatever right you think of what Russia
has done in Georgia it doesn't compare
to the kind of confrontations that were
taking place during the Cold War when
literally both sides had these huge
nuclear arsenals on trigger alert
there's some parallels between Putin and
Kristoff from the way they sort of react
because they're aggrieved by the United
States
I think you know there's a time for
diplomacy in a time for a hard-line I
wrote a piece about this for the outlook
section of the post a couple of weeks
ago so I didn't want to go into all that
again and we we've all heard the stories
of which you mentioned about the how
Khrushchev dislike entity at the Vienna
conference and how much superior to him
he thought he was and yet in Khrushchev
memoirs he has nothing with nice things
to say about Kennedy was that part of
the deal well well the memoirs were
written in in completely different
circumstances that he was then a reach I
read this is 20 years or so later he's
sitting in his - up and he's ruminating
about events and it probably that
happens to a lot of a lot of people you
know after two decades you develop a
sense of perspective and I think also
although he had a low opinion of Chris
job of Kennedy at Vienna he regained he
gained a high opinion of him as a result
of coming through this you know
extraordinary crisis in October 1962
that the Soviet leadership and
particularly Khrushchev credited
Kennedy's sort of human qualities with
helping to get us through that period
and I think it worked you know the other
way around that both leaders discovered
that the other was not just an
ideological enemy he was also a human
being with sort of who wanted to survive
and wanted his country to survive not
all they're wrong well thank you very
much I think we've done come to the end
thank you thank you
from the 2008 National Book Festival in
Washington DC we just saw Washington
Post reporter Michael Dobbs talk about
his book one minute to midnight Kennedy
Khrushchev